my name is David Gant I always felt I
was destined for a life of adventure it
didn't quite pan out that way Barry is
the man of your dreams it's like you're
marrying both of us David me and Mama
don't speak man one night I met miss
Kelly Campbell what would you do with a
million dollars probably start my own
business maybe be a bounty hunter huh
you know put that bullet just went
straight between your cheeks yeah feels
like it just grazed my biscuits right
there betwixt them Kelly tells me you
all work together over at Loomis that
strikes me as an incredible opportunity
you talk about robbing a bike how are
gonna be
remote up a truck dad you drive away
police are calling it one of the largest
cash heists ever 17 million miss stories
are now searching for this slab okay
look like Kenny Rogers and Kenny Loggins
had a lovechild and then Kenny G he just
showed up to the birthday party started
playing a flute and messed this boy up
let's go what billion zillion baby it's
time to cut David GAMP from the TV we
can't do this this is wrong
so who y'all want me to kill whoa okay
not now not in front of is one of them
no boys go upstairs right now y'all a
little bit
because there were not
save timers double-cross me yeah bright
here Sugarbush okay don't worry about
fight Oh Lord us a cheap door you gotta
give me a three count next time I should
boob except sometimes the only way out
is through Oh
so you can have love but you ran away
cuz nobody loves you
Shh shut up you can't just say
everything that comes into your head
that's bad talking